people in turkey and Syria are once
again scared and shaken two more
powerful earthquakes have rocked both
countries two weeks after devastating
Tremors killed more than 47 000 people
well the epicenter of Monday night's
stronger magnitude 6.4 Quake was now the
city of antakia buildings that were
already weak and have now collapsed
killing at least six people and parents
are left console in their terrified
children yet again in Northwest Syria
people fled buildings as a shaking began
the white helmets volunteer group
reported more than 130 injuries I said
vague begins our coverage from hatai in
Tokyo
three more victims to add to the tens of
thousands of people who have already
lost their lives
[Music]
four men were trapped inside this
building only one made it out to life
they'd come to salvage what they could
of their belongings when the earthquake
hit
the third in the space of two weeks
their family members waiting hoping
their relatives would be brought out
alive
instead they saw their loved ones
carried out in body bags
rescue workers had been winding down
their operations when the earthquake
struck
we were planning to go back to our homes
this earthquake has extended the process
we never left the rescue operation we
continued our fight did our best to pull
out people alive
[Applause]
elsewhere a building that had survived
two earthquakes in southern turkey now
gone
[Music]
somewhere in hatai Province the car dash
cam captures the moment
[Music]
a woman screams the Earth trembled all
the buildings in hattai have collapsed
they are dead
and at the airport Panic as a quick hit
a politician's TV interview from an Aid
distribution center interrupted
[Music]
for families already traumatized
disbelief the terror has come again
scared we thought the ground would tear
apart
a nation rocked just two weeks after
twin earthquakes appended the lives of
millions killing tens of thousands and
destroying countless homes it
it was very difficult you know you know
it was gonna happen we we were expecting
that so
right now so we're expecting more
so everybody should be you know
more prepared about this
this is the moment the Quake struck
Aleppo in rebel-hulled Northern Syria
more misery for people suffering severe
shortages in food medicine and housing
on top of a decade-old civil war
families are already sleeping on the
streets in freezing conditions
back in turkey's mayor says people are
trapped under the rubble people poured
into the streets another night in the
cold as a sense of fear prevailed there
have been thousands of aftershocks and
this latest earthquake has people asking
where they can go to be safe Assad
tortilla
when Robert McBride joins us live now
from Daphne the epicenter of Monday's
Quake Robert tell us more about these
latest earthquakes
that's right these are two Quakes really
adding more misery and suffering to an
area and people that have already
suffered so much this is the District of
Daphne this is on the edge of the city
of antakia one of the cities that
suffered so much of the devastation of
this uh earthquake two weeks ago and
this was the epicenter of one of those
Quakes it happened at about 8 P.M local
time here it was measured 6.4 in
magnitude so it was a substantial uh
Quake here and it happened at a time
when people were coming back to
buildings and already already been
damaged and have been looking through
sifting through uh what used to be their
homes looking for possessions we're on a
one street that has seen now extra
damage this building here this used to
be a five-story building like the
buildings either side of it this had
been damaged in the initial Quake but
had still been standing sadly people
tragically were back inside this
building when this second Quake happened
and Rescue has had to recover three
bodies from this one building all down
this street we are told by um the
soldiers who've been here for a week now
who they've said that the Quake from
Monday night has completely changed once
again uh the the look of this street
this street was already very badly
damaged you as you walk along here
already some of the buildings were
already gone they were turned into piles
of rubble other buildings though were
still standing they may have been
toppled over to one stand one side that
they were still standing even though
they were damaged some of those
buildings are even further damaged or as
we've already seen a number of the
buildings completely collapsed once more
adding to these piles of rubble here
Wendy devastating scenes there and Rob
the recovery effort from the original
earthquakes was challenging enough but
this will surely make matters even worse
that's right here in antakia I think on
a Sunday they announced the last actual
rescue operation looking for survivors
in one building so officially on Sunday
the actual rescuer efforts uh had
stopped they are now moving into the
recovery phase and still with the people
who are living in their thousands in
tented cities all around here and other
cities they have been wanting to get
back into buildings to try to get
possessions what they can salvage again
this has thrown all of that uh into
confusion that it has raised alarm
people who were once again living out in
the streets under tents were once again
outside reliving if you like all of the
trauma of living through earthquakes
once more and since Sunday and since
Monday night's earthquakes we have been
having literally scores of more
aftershocks so it is a incredible
concern for everybody who is here trying
to rebuild their lives and wondering
when that's going to happen also for the
construction effort that is meant to get
underway as we were driving through
antacia our producer was just pointing
out all of the different registration
plates of literally hundreds and
thousands of vehicles of diggers of
excavators that are all being brought to
this part of turkey a to to start the
effort of clearing away Rubble of
reconstruction but all of that clearly
is on hold while we wait to see what
other Tremors what other Quakes we might
have in this already are very badly
affected area Rob McBride thank you
we're staying with this resource said uh
joins us live from the alham crossing
near the North Western Syrian City a
friend Russell how are people coping
with earthquakes
foreign
gate here has been opened in 2018 after
turkey conducted a military incursion in
Syria and since then it was usually used
for the military purposes however after
the earthquake now it is being also used
for the humanitarian Aid as well not far
from here just 10 kilometers away
there's a town of genderes and 25
kilometers deeper there is Afrin so
these two cities for these two towns
particularly were hit very bad here and
at the at as a result more than seven
thousands more than 6 000 people have
died 150
000 people are now displaced again so
and also there are many more thousands
that are still waiting for the help and
they are injured so I have been talking
to the syrians here so now they are
suffering from the shortage of the Clean
Water the is no electricity no heaters
here not proper blankets as well
particularly for children it is quite
difficult here and also the rescue of
force here has not been a deck weight so
on the Turkish side we have seen that
the roaring noise of the escalators the
diggers heavy lifting machineries and
also thousands of the professional
Rescuers days and night relentlessly
working to save the lives there but when
you come to the Syrian side it's
completely silence the Silence of grief
Silence of Abandonment and they lack the
modern equipment indeed they were using
very much rudimentary equipment and even
sometimes with their bare hands trying
to pull out their loved ones loved ones
out of the rubbles here so that that was
many that was one of the main problems
here the lack of the international Aid
that arrived very late only days after
the earthquake hit this region the
International Air started to get in
however ever it is very much little and
they say it is very much it's too late
as well they feel syrians here they feel
that they're abundant they're forgotten
by the International Community and they
said that they've always was not heard
through the last more than a decade of
the Civil War and now they're caught in
another disaster so here in Syria the
disasters are just just overlapping and
when it comes to the health facilities
though that is hosting those who have
the thousands that have been injured so
they are either collapsed or heavily
damaged or they do not have any modern
medical equipment and usually they do
not have the proper stuff as well so
that's why life here is quite difficult
and also throughout the last two weeks
we have seen hundreds and hundreds of
the Syrian families who fled the war in
Syria almost a decade ago came to Turkey
to to begin a safe life and now they are
also now getting back to Syria some of
them to to attend the funerals of their
loved ones some of them to meet up the
survivors and also on top of that we had
the officials are saying that more than
1 500 dead bodies belonging to Syrian
refugees in Turkey have been taken back
to Syria to be buried in their home
country so that is now the situation of
them these people that millions of the
peoples who left Syria came to Turkey to
begin a new safe life now they're caught
in in another disaster and they're back
to where they started so they now have
to restart from scratch
that's all for now thanks for that
update
Omar al-harani reports from Afrin where
people are forced to sleep on the ground
this is a football pitch in the middle
of a friend City where residents flocked
and panic following the most recent
earthquake and subsequent tremors
as you can see in the absence of tents
people are lying on the ground spending
the night here for fear of imminent
shakes many of them are survivors who
lost their homes in the first two
earthquakes two weeks ago their
sufferings have not come to an end now
there's the shortage of shelter food and
medical supplies it's by all measures
nothing but a tragedy in the northern
part of Syria amid a poor response from
the International Community the recent
earthquake has exacerbated their
sufferings we witnessed the state of
overwhelming Panic reminiscent of the
early moments of the first earthquake
that hit the area on February 6th
um a friend Aleppo Countryside